hi this is pressure Locker in this video
I'm going to teach you a card trick that
involves rolling three dice here's how
the trick looks to the spectator you
start out with three dice and a standard
deck of cards you give the deck a
shuffle and then you explain the trick
will depend on the roll of the dice so
you give the spectator the dice and you
let them roll it in this case they roll
a 5 a 3 and a 2
the numbers 5 3 & 2 add up to 10 and
what you do is you count out the number
of cards equal to the sum of the numbers
on the dice so we count out 10 cards now
what we're going to do is we're going to
shuffle the cards again we remove the
middle number which is 3 and we're going
to count out 7 cards which is the sum of
the remaining dice so we count out 7
cards put the deck on top and then we do
this 3 times because the trick involves
3 dice so we count out 7 cards put the
deck on top and then we count out 7
cards again and then we put the deck on
top now we've gone through a long
process but you're gonna be able to
predict the card you're gonna tell the
spectator I know this is the ace of
spades so it's a pretty cool trick
because there's no way you could have
known what they were gonna roll there's
no way you could have known what the
middle number was but still you were
able to figure out what the card was on
top of the pile so let's try the trick
again we have a roll of 4 3 & 2 so this
adds up to 9 so we're going to count out
9 cards
then what we're going to do is we're
going to remove the middle number of
three and the remaining dice add up to
six so we count out six cards put the
remaining cards on top of it we count
out six cards again put the remaining
cards on top and we do this three times
so the third time we count out six cards
and we put the remaining cards on top
and once again we're going to be able to
predict that the top card is the ace of
spades
so I'll do the trick one more time just
to explain one more variation we give it
a rifle shuffle and then we roll out we
roll the dice
this time we have six six and five which
adds up to 17 so we're going to need to
card count out 17 cards which is the sum
of the numbers on the dice now we have 6
6 7 5 the middle number will be 6 so we
remove one of the sixes so we're left
with 11 and then we do the same thing we
count out 11 cards we put the rest of
the cards on top and we do this three
times and lo and behold when you do this
on the third time you're going to put
the cards down and you're gonna say hey
I know what this card on top is it's the
ace of spades so here's the final detail
you need to know to do the trick the
only thing you really need to know is
you memorize the value of the card on
top of the deck then you proceed with
the directions that I've given you in
the video and when you're done with that
process you will always end up that the
card on top will be the same as the
first card in the deck that you
memorized so this trick is
mathematically complicated to explain
but trust me it works every time and
it's pretty impressive because there's
no way you could have predicted what the
numbers on the dice were I hope you
liked this video please subscribe to my
channel you can support me on patreon
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
on Twitter at pressure Locker and you
can get my books listed on my website